Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the restishistory.com and join the club. That is, the rest is history.com. This episode is brought to you by SAP. With investors, customers, and workers demanding more from your business,
感谢您收听《历史就是如此》（The Rest is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 restishistory.com 加入俱乐部。没错，就是 restishistory.com。本期节目由 SAP 赞助播出。随着投资者、客户和员工对您的业务提出更高要求，
it's time to try SAP. Its AI-powered capabilities can help you streamline costs, connect with new suppliers and manage payroll even when your business is being pulled in different directions to deliver a quality product at a fair price while paying your people what they're worth too so your business can stay unfazed. Learn more at SAP.com slash uncertainty. This episode is brought to you by SAP. With investors, customers, and workers demanding more from your business, it's time to try SAP. Its AI-powered capabilities can help you streamline costs. Connect with new suppliers and manage payroll
是时候尝试 SAP 了。其人工智能驱动的功能可以帮助您精简成本、对接新供应商并管理薪资，即使您的业务在多方压力下仍需以合理的价格提供优质产品，同时还要确保员工获得应有的报酬，从而让您的业务保持从容不迫。欲了解更多信息，请访问 SAP.com/uncertainty。本期节目由 SAP 赞助播出。随着投资者、客户和员工对您的业务提出更高要求，是时候尝试 SAP 了。其人工智能驱动的功能可以帮助您精简成本、对接新供应商并管理薪资，
even when your business is being pulled in different directions to deliver a quality product at a fair price while paying your people what they're worth too so your business can stay unfazed. Learn more at SAP.com slash uncertainty. This episode is sponsored by Hive. History has always been a story of power who seeks it, who seizes it,
即使您的业务在多方压力下仍需以合理的价格提供优质产品，同时还要确保员工获得应有的报酬，从而让您的业务保持从容不迫。欲了解更多信息，请访问 SAP.com/uncertainty。本期节目由 Hive 赞助播出。历史一直是一个关于权力的故事：谁在寻求权力，谁在攫取权力，
and how easily it can also. slip away. The Caesars, the Caliphs, the Tsars, they conquered vast swaths of the world, they proclaimed themselves, the favourites of the gods, and yet their empires crumbled away. It is easier to conquer than it is to control. Hive takes a different approach. It puts power where it belongs in your hands. They started with smart thermostats, and they've been. now gone much further. Solar panels, heat pumps, EV chargers, all working together so that you can power your home in your own way. That's genuine empowerment. Checking your phone, seeing the
以及它又是如何轻易地溜走的。凯撒、哈里发、沙皇，他们征服了广袤的土地，宣称自己是神的宠儿，然而他们的帝国最终还是土崩瓦解了。征服容易，治理难。Hive 采取了不同的方式。它将权力交还给它所属的地方——您的手中。他们从智能恒温器起家，现在已经走得更远。太阳能电池板、热泵、电动汽车充电器，所有这些协同工作，让您可以按照自己的方式为家庭供电。这才是真正的赋权。查看手机，看到
heating's on, the car's charging and the sun is quietly earning its keep on the roof. Caesar never had to charge his chariots, but I'm sure he would have admired the efficiency. Visit hive.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability, Hive compatible with selected technology. Now, as my lady Elizabeth is put from that degree she was in, and what degree she is at now I know not by hearsay, I know not how to order her or myself or her women or groom.
暖气开着，汽车正在充电，太阳也在屋顶上静静地为您创造价值。凯撒从不需要给他的战车充电，但我相信他一定会钦佩这种效率。访问 hive.com 了解更多信息。需视勘察和适用性而定，Hive 与特定技术兼容。现在，由于我的伊丽莎白女士被剥夺了她曾经拥有的地位，至于她现在的地位，我从传闻中不得而知，我也不知道该如何安排她、我自己、她的女仆或马夫。
Rooms, I beg you to be good lord to her and hers, and that she may have raiment, for she has neither gown, nor curtail, nor petticoat, nor linen for smocks, nor kerchiefs, sleeves, rails, bodices, handkerchiefs, mufflers, nor caps. So, we'll discover who that was in a couple of moments. Is it Mrs. Thatcher? No, it definitely was not. But these are very, very dark days for the infant, Elizabeth, the first as she will become. She's not yet three years old, but she doesn't have enough mufflers. There's no kerchiefs. There's no curtail.
房间，我恳求您对她和她的人好一点，让她有衣服穿，因为她既没有长袍，也没有短裙，没有衬裙，没有亚麻内衣，没有头巾、袖子、围裙、胸衣、手帕、围巾，也没有帽子。所以，我们稍后会揭晓那是谁。是撒切尔夫人吗？不，绝对不是。但对于还是婴儿的伊丽莎白（未来的伊丽莎白一世）来说，这些日子非常非常黑暗。她还不到三岁，但她连围巾都没有。没有头巾，没有短裙。
There's no gown. There's no bodice. And there's no mummy. This is a terrible, terrible scene. So if you listen to our previous episode, well, if you didn't listen to our previous episode, what are you doing? But if you listen to our previous episode and recall it, you will know that Elizabeth's father, Henry the 8th, has severed the head of her mother, Anne Boleyn, because he's fed up with her being a bit of a nag and also fed up with her not giving him a son. And he is very keen to marry his new lady
没有长袍，没有胸衣，也没有妈妈。这是一个非常非常可怕的场景。所以，如果你听了我们上一集节目——好吧，如果你没听，你在干什么？但如果你听了上一集并记得内容，你就会知道伊丽莎白的父亲亨利八世砍下了她母亲安妮·博林的头，因为他受够了她的唠叨，也受够了她没能为他生下一个儿子。他非常渴望娶他的新欢，
friend, the excitingly boring Jane Seymour. So Anne is out. Mummy is dead. And we ended last time by saying, what will this mean for Elizabeth I first and how will she fare in the snake pit of Henry's court. And now we will find out. And the first bit of bad news, no handkerchiefs. Yeah. So, Tom, let's put people out to their misery. That was not Margaret Thatcher.
那个令人兴奋的无聊女人简·西摩。所以安妮出局了，妈妈死了。我们上次结束时说，这对伊丽莎白一世意味着什么，她在亨利那充满蛇蝎的宫廷中会过得怎么样。现在我们将揭晓答案。第一个坏消息是，没有手帕。是的。那么，汤姆，让我们结束人们的痛苦吧。那不是玛格丽特·撒切尔。
That was Lady Brian. Yeah, which is a great name, I think. And Lady Brian is the sort of Mary Poppins. Yeah, so she's in her 60s. She's actually Elizabeth's great aunt. And so she was the obvious choice to serve Elizabeth as her lady mistress, as it was known, which is, as you said, a kind of very posh, Mary Poppins. And Lady Brian is facing up to the fact that Elizabeth, who previously had been so fated, had been so privileged, now suddenly all that privilege seems to have gone.
那是布莱恩夫人。是的，我认为这是一个很棒的名字。布莱恩夫人就像是玛丽·波平斯。是的，她已经60多岁了。她实际上是伊丽莎白的姑祖母。所以她是担任伊丽莎白女管家（Lady Mistress）的不二人选，正如你所说，这是一种非常高级的“玛丽·波平斯”。布莱恩夫人正面对这样一个事实：伊丽莎白曾经如此受宠、如此尊贵，现在突然间，所有的特权似乎都消失了。
And poor Elizabeth, you know, not yet four, is kind of immersed in effectively a very dark fairy tale. So she's no longer the heir to the throne. She's now officially proclaimed a bastard. She's no longer a princess. She's just the lady Elizabeth. Henry the 8th has ordered that she be kept from his sight. So she had been at Greenwich Palace when her mother was executed. She's been sent away.
可怜的伊丽莎白，还不到四岁，就沉浸在一个非常黑暗的童话故事里。她不再是王位继承人，现在被正式宣布为私生女。她不再是公主，只是伊丽莎白女士。亨利八世下令不准让她出现在自己视线内。所以当她母亲被处决时，她还在格林威治宫，现在她被送走了。
Henry doesn't want her there. And Henry's also ordered that her household be cut back. And then on top of that, there's this further cruelty. So to quote David Starkey in his book, Apprenticeship, The shower of lovely clothes which Anne Boleyn had lavished on her daughter suddenly dried up. And in fact, as Starkey points out, this wasn't conscious cruelty on Henry's part, but it was still neglect. It's still expressive of the fact that he's.
亨利不想见到她。亨利还下令削减她的家庭开支。除此之外，还有更进一步的残酷。引用大卫·斯塔基在《学徒生涯》一书中的话：“安妮·博林曾经挥霍在女儿身上的漂亮衣服突然断供了。”事实上，正如斯塔基指出的那样，这并非亨利有意的残酷，但仍然是一种忽视。这依然表达了一个事实，那就是他……
not really bothered about Elizabeth anymore. And definitely Henry has his mind on other things than worrying about his baby daughter. Right. Jane Seymour specifically, right? Because just 10, 11 days after Anne Berlin has been executed, he gets married to Jane Seymour. He does. And he sails with her down the Thames to Greenwich, which is, of course, the palace where Anne had been arrested. And Jane, who had been the lady in waiting to Anne now presides in Greenwich as queen. Henry also has another issue on his mind, which is what to do with his elder daughter, Mary, who has been a permanent source of annoyance to him ever since he got rid of Mary's mother, Catherine of Aragon.
不再关心伊丽莎白了。毫无疑问，亨利的心思都在别处，而不是担心他年幼的女儿。没错，是简·西摩，对吧？因为在安妮·博林被处决仅10到11天后，他就娶了简·西摩。确实如此。他带着她沿泰晤士河航行到格林威治，那当然就是安妮被捕的宫殿。而曾经是安妮侍女的简，现在作为王后在格林威治主持大局。亨利还有另一件事要操心，那就是如何处理他的长女玛丽，自从他抛弃玛丽的母亲阿拉贡的凯瑟琳以来，她一直是让他头疼的根源。
Mary by now is 20. She remains devoted to the memory of her mother, who'd been unceremoniously dumped by Henry Vranbelin. She is devoted to not just the memory of her mother, who's dead by now, but also to the faith of her mother, traditional Catholic faith. And so she's absolutely obdurate in her refusal to accept that Henry might be the head of the Church of England rather than the Pope. And this has been the sticking point between Henry and Mary ever since Henry's supremacy over the Church of England was announced. But now, in the wake of Ambelin's death, she does kind of briefly waver. And I think in part because Jane, unlike Anne, shows Mary great favour.
玛丽现在已经20岁了。她仍然忠于她母亲的记忆，她母亲被亨利和安妮·博林无情地抛弃了。她不仅忠于她母亲（现在已经去世）的记忆，还忠于她母亲的信仰——传统的罗马天主教信仰。因此，她极其顽固地拒绝承认亨利可能是英国教会的首脑，而不是教皇。自从亨利宣布他拥有英国教会的最高权力以来，这就是亨利和玛丽之间的症结所在。但现在，在安妮·博林死后，她确实短暂地动摇了。我认为部分原因是简与安妮不同，她对玛丽表现出了极大的善意。
She's very kind to her. Yeah. I mean, we said Jane was boring. Jane is a very nice person, isn't she? Yeah, I think so. I applaud Jane for this. And I think also Mary must be missing her father. I mean, she hasn't seen him for years.
她对她非常好。是的。我的意思是，我们说简很无聊。简是一个非常好的人，不是吗？是的，我想是这样。我为简的这一点鼓掌。而且我认为玛丽一定很想念她的父亲。我的意思是，她已经好几年没见过他了。
You know, he's basically banished her because she's been so annoying. And so Henry senses his opportunity to finally get Mary to submit. And so he sends down a party of peers and they ride down to see Mary in Hertfordshire. And they convince her to yield. And they tell her, if she was their daughter, they would beat her and knock her head so violently against the wall that they would make it as soft as baked apples. And it has to be said, you know, there's quite a lot of violence being threatened against Mary. Yeah.
你知道，他基本上把她流放了，因为她太烦人了。所以亨利感觉到机会来了，终于可以让玛丽屈服了。于是他派出一队贵族，骑马去赫特福德郡见玛丽。他们说服她屈服。他们告诉她，如果她是他们的女儿，他们会打她，把她的头猛烈地撞在墙上，直到把她的头撞得像烤苹果一样软。必须说，你知道，对玛丽的暴力威胁确实不少。是的。
I mean, imagine that, if you're a 20-year-old girl and all these blokes and Gilles turn up and start saying they're going to splash your head against the wall. Yeah. Anyway, finally, she submits. She signs the articles that acknowledge Henry's head of the English church. And, of course, this is a surrender that also requires her to acknowledge that her mother's marriage to her father had been. incestuous and unlawful. And it's really the one moment in her life when she buckles, when she doesn't stick to her principles. So Nicola Tallis in her book on Young Elizabeth writes, she would never forgive herself for what she believed to be the ultimate portrayal
我的意思是，想象一下，如果你是一个20岁的女孩，所有这些男人都跑过来，开始说他们要把你的头撞在墙上。是的。总之，最后她屈服了。她签署了承认亨利为英国教会首脑的条款。当然，这种投降也要求她承认她母亲与她父亲的婚姻是乱伦且非法的。这确实是她一生中唯一一次屈服，唯一一次没有坚持原则。所以尼古拉·塔利斯在关于年轻伊丽莎白的书里写道，她永远不会原谅自己，因为她认为这是对她母亲记忆的终极背叛。
of her mother's memory. And I think in the long run, actually it serves just to make her even more determined to uphold her principles. Yeah. Now, in the last episode, I revealed myself as, although not an admirer of Mary's ideological position, a great admirer of Mary is a person. And actually, she now behaves very nicely to Elizabeth, doesn't she? Because she and Elizabeth are now equal, because Elizabeth has been declared a bastard as well. And Mary turns out to be a very nice sister, older sister for Elizabeth. So people always think of them at daggers-drawn, but that's not entirely the case. No. So she says, from this point on, I shall never call her by other name than sister.
从长远来看，这实际上只会让她更加坚定地维护自己的原则。是的。现在，在上一集中，我透露了自己虽然不欣赏玛丽的意识形态立场，但我非常欣赏玛丽这个人。事实上，她现在对伊丽莎白表现得非常好，不是吗？因为她和伊丽莎白现在平等了，因为伊丽莎白也被宣布为私生女。玛丽成了一个非常好的姐姐，伊丽莎白的姐姐。所以人们总是认为她们水火不容，但事实并非完全如此。不。所以她说，从现在起，我永远不会叫她别的名字，只会叫她妹妹。
No longer is she that little bastard. She's now her sister. And as you say, she's very loving. She gives Elizabeth all kinds of toys, plays with her, all kinds of things like that. And she even amazingly brings herself to pray for the soul of Anne Boleyn. That's pretty magnanimous, given how Amber Lynn had treated her. That really is. Yeah.
她不再是那个小私生女了。她现在是她的妹妹。正如你所说，她非常有爱心。她给伊丽莎白各种各样的玩具，和她一起玩，诸如此类的事情。她甚至令人惊讶地为安妮·博林的灵魂祈祷。考虑到安妮·博林曾经如何对待她，这真是太宽宏大量了。确实如此。是的。
So again, to quote David Starkey on Mary, he says that she was tender-hearted to excess when issues of principle were not involved. Like me. I thought that you were flinty-hearted. even when issues of principle weren't involved? No, I think actually I'm a very sentimental person. Do you? Okay.
所以，再次引用大卫·斯塔基对玛丽的评价，他说当不涉及原则问题时，她心肠软得过分。像我一样。我以为你是个铁石心肠的人，即使在不涉及原则问题时也是如此？不，我认为实际上我是一个非常感性的人。是吗？好吧。
Go on. Continue. So Elizabeth. So what about her? She's a very precocious little girl, but also I think profoundly unsettled and must be in a state of some bewilderment because she is aware of her change in circumstances. So there's this comment she makes to the man who's essentially responsible for her security. And she says, why, governor?
继续。所以伊丽莎白。那么她呢？她是一个非常早熟的小女孩，但也非常不安，一定处于某种困惑的状态，因为她意识到自己处境的变化。所以她对那个本质上负责她安全的人说了这样的话。她说，为什么，总督？
how happy yesterday lady princess and today but lady elizabeth and so at some point obviously she is told about what has happened to her mother we don't know when and as far as we can tell from our extant sources she never really mentions anne's name and i think it's clear why she doesn't because her claim to the throne is massively not helped by the fact that her mother had her head chopped off yeah for treason she clearly does hold Anne's memory in her heart because as Queen, she will surround herself with any number of Berlin relatives. And she owns this locket ring made a mother of pearl and studied with diamonds and rubies. And when she opened it, it revealed paired miniature
昨天还是快乐的公主殿下，今天却只是伊丽莎白女士。所以，在某个时候，她显然被告知了她母亲身上发生的事情。我们不知道是什么时候，据我们现有的资料来看，她从未真正提起过安妮的名字。我认为原因很清楚，因为她母亲被砍了头，这对于她继承王位来说，并没有什么帮助。是的，因为叛国罪。她显然把安妮的记忆珍藏在心里，因为作为女王，她身边会有许多博林家族的亲戚。她拥有一枚珍珠母贝制成的挂坠戒指，上面镶嵌着钻石和红宝石。当她打开它时，里面露出了成对的微型
portraits, so one of herself and one of Anne. So clearly, the memory of Anne does matter to her. but the fact she doesn't talk about it, perhaps may be expressive of a kind of buried trauma as well as of kind of political sense. How much would she genuinely remember of Anne, though? I don't think she would remember anything. But I think the notion that her mother had been executed by her father must be a kind of deep psychic wound. I can't believe it would have been anything other than that. Fair enough. People who are interested in exploring the nuances of it, Tracy Borman's book, Amber Lynn Elizabeth, is really, really good on the whole subject.
肖像，一张是她自己的，一张是安妮的。所以很明显，安妮的记忆对她来说确实很重要。但她不谈论这件事的事实，也许既表达了一种深埋的创伤，也表达了一种政治敏感性。不过，她对安妮到底能有多少真正的记忆呢？我不认为她会记得任何事情。但我认为，她母亲被她父亲处决这一事实，一定是一种深刻的心理创伤。我无法相信这会是其他任何东西。有道理。对这些细微差别感兴趣的人，特蕾西·博曼关于安妮·博林和伊丽莎白的书，在整个主题上写得非常好。
Let's get to the really important issue, which is the lack of handkerchiefs. Lady Brian. Lady Brian has complained, no girdle, no bodice. That's crucial lack. Is that ever addressed? It is. So Elizabeth's clothing allowance is upgraded. She gets her cachiefs and curtels and all that kind of thing.
让我们谈谈真正重要的问题，也就是缺乏手帕。布莱恩夫人。布莱恩夫人抱怨说，没有腰带，没有胸衣。那是关键的缺失。这解决了吗？解决了。所以伊丽莎白的服装津贴提高了。她得到了她的头巾、短裙和所有那些东西。
But I think that despite that, there's no question that she is now growing up, conscious of being second best to her elder sister, Mary. Because Jane Seymour, you know, really fusses over Mary, does her best to make her feel happy, but pretty much ignores Elizabeth. And again, you can see why. Yeah. I mean, just as Mary had been a reminder to Anne Boleyn of Henry's first wife. So Elizabeth is a reminder to Jane Seymour of his second wife.
但我认为，尽管如此，毫无疑问，她现在长大了，意识到自己比姐姐玛丽次要。因为简·西摩，你知道，真的对玛丽很关照，尽力让她感到快乐，但基本上忽略了伊丽莎白。同样，你可以看出原因。是的。我的意思是，正如玛丽曾是安妮·博林提醒亨利第一任妻子的存在一样，伊丽莎白也是简·西摩提醒亨利第二任妻子的存在。
So you can understand the psychology of it. And then on the 12th of October 1547, Elizabeth becomes third best because that is when Jane gives Henry a son. And although Jane dies two weeks later, this son, Edward, survives. And this means at last Henry has his male heir. And it also means for Elizabeth that she loses the services of Lady Brian, which is very sad because she is now assigned as Lady Mistress to the Young Prince, because she's the best lady mistress in the business. And so obviously, the young Prince must have her.
所以你可以理解其中的心理。然后在1547年10月12日，伊丽莎白变成了第三顺位，因为那是简给亨利生下儿子的时候。虽然简在两周后去世了，但这个儿子爱德华活了下来。这意味着亨利终于有了男性继承人。这也意味着伊丽莎白失去了布莱恩夫人的服务，这非常令人难过，因为她现在被指派为小王子的女管家，因为她是业内最好的女管家。所以很明显，小王子必须有她。
But I think, again, this must have been a blow to Elizabeth because clearly Lady Brian had kind of filled the maternal void left by Anne's execution. And Elizabeth, by this point, I mean, she's only just four. You know, she's lost her mother, who she presumably barely remembers, and now she's her mother substitute. And again, I don't think it's over-psychologizing to see that this must have had an impact on Elizabeth, because from this point on, she always forms very, very intense relationships with her personal attendance and hugs them very close to her.
但我认为，这对于伊丽莎白来说一定是一个打击，因为很明显，布莱恩夫人填补了安妮被处决后留下的母爱空白。而伊丽莎白，到这个时候，我的意思是，她才刚满四岁。你知道，她失去了母亲，她大概几乎不记得她了，现在又失去了她的母亲替代者。同样，我不认为过度心理分析会认为这一定对伊丽莎白产生了影响，因为从这一点开始，她总是与她的私人侍从建立非常、非常亲密的关系，并把她们紧紧地抱在身边。
And once she's decided that an attendant is loyal to her, she will basically never let her go. Yeah. Even great characters in history, human beings first and foremost. And a child who's had a very disruptive and traumatic beginning. to their life is bound to want to find maternal figures to whom they can cling for affection. And that's the case, isn't it, with the very first of these. So Lady Brian has gone and there's a series of governesses. The first one has the splendid sort of American style name of Catherine Champanown.
一旦她认定一个侍从对她忠诚，她基本上就永远不会让她离开。是的。即使是历史上的伟大人物，首先也是人类。一个在生命之初就经历了非常混乱和创伤的孩子，必然会想要寻找可以依附以获取情感的母亲形象。这就是伊丽莎白的情况，不是吗？布莱恩夫人走了，随后是一系列的家庭教师。第一个有着非常华丽的、美式风格的名字，叫凯瑟琳·钱珀诺。
Is that right? I mean, what the name is that? Kate. Yeah, Kate Champanown. She will stick with Elizabeth up to her death decades in the future. So people who've watched Blackadder. Yeah. To the degree that anyone is Nersy in Blackadder.
是这样吗？我的意思是，那是什么名字？凯特。是的，凯特·钱珀诺。她将陪伴伊丽莎白直到她几十年后去世。所以看过《黑爵士》（Blackadder）的人。是的。在某种程度上，任何人都是《黑爵士》里的保姆。
Yeah. Kate is. So Queen Elizabeth in Blackadder is very spoiled. You know, schoolgirl. Yeah. And Nersie is kind of absolute dimwit. Tis but the twinkling of a toe since you could say nothing but Lizzie go plop, plop, Lizzie go plop, plop.
是的，凯特就是。所以《黑爵士》里的伊丽莎白女王非常被宠坏。你知道，女学生。是的。而保姆是一个绝对的笨蛋。自从你只能说“莉兹去噗噗，莉兹去噗噗”以来，这只是脚趾的一闪而过。
So she's a kind of idiot in Blackadder. It has to be said that Kate Champanown is absolutely not an idiot. Yeah. She's an amazing woman. She's a great scholar. She's a humanist. She's an evangelical. And she's probably the person who in her life, I would guess, Elizabeth loves more than
所以她在《黑爵士》里是个白痴。必须说，凯特·钱珀诺绝对不是白痴。是的。她是一个了不起的女人。她是一位伟大的学者。她是一位人文主义者。她是一位福音派信徒。她可能是伊丽莎白一生中，我猜，比
anyone else. And Elizabeth says of Kate, she have taken great labor and pain in bringing of me up in learning and honesty. So, you know, that's a fine tribute. But I think credit is also due to Elizabeth herself, because it is already becoming apparent, you know, when she's still quite young, that she's really very, very smart. And there were specialists in education who worried that Kate was actually pushing Elizabeth too far. And one of these people was a man who wasn't just England's foremost Greek scholar, but was also the greatest educationalist in the country. And this is a guy called Roger Asham, who again like Kate is an evangelical. So there's a kind of sense that humanist scholarship, evangelical beliefs, devotion to education, it's part of the
任何人都更爱的人。伊丽莎白评价凯特说：“她在培养我的学识和诚实方面付出了巨大的劳动和心血。”所以，你知道，这是一个很好的赞美。但我认为伊丽莎白本人也值得称赞，因为当她还很小的时候，就已经显现出她真的非常、非常聪明。当时有教育专家担心凯特实际上把伊丽莎白逼得太紧了。其中一个人不仅是英国首屈一指的希腊语学者，也是全国最伟大的教育家。这个人叫罗杰·阿沙姆，他像凯特一样也是福音派信徒。所以有一种感觉，人文主义学术、福音派信仰、对教育的奉献，这是伊丽莎白所处环境的一部分。
swell that Elizabeth is in. But Ashan thinks, oh, you know, we mustn't hurry this. We mustn't push it too far. But actually, on this occasion, he's wrong, because Elizabeth really flourishes under Kate's educational regime to the degree that in December 1539, one of Henry's courtiers comes to Hatfield, where Elizabeth is based, to pay a courtesy call. She's six years old at this time. He talks to her, and he's completely stunned by what he finds. And he reports back to Henry, if she be no more educated than she now appeareth to be, she will prove of no less honor in womanhood than she'll be seen her father's daughter. So in other words, you know, she's a massive chip off the old block.
但阿沙姆认为，哦，你知道，我们不能操之过急。我们不能逼得太紧。但实际上，这一次他错了，因为伊丽莎白在凯特的教育制度下确实蓬勃发展，以至于在1539年12月，亨利的一位朝臣来到伊丽莎白所在的哈特菲尔德进行礼节性拜访。她当时六岁。他与她交谈，被她的表现完全惊呆了。他向亨利报告说：“如果她受到的教育不比她现在表现出来的多，她成年后将表现出不亚于她父亲女儿的荣誉。”换句话说，你知道，她简直就是她父亲的翻版。
Yeah. And actually, this courtier says she's as smart as a woman of 40 years old. So very, very impressive. And from this point on, you know, Henry is sufficiently intrigued that he wants regular updates on Elizabeth's progress. And this isn't just her progress as a scholar, but also her abilities as a musician, which matters to Henry a lot. You know, can she dance? Can she sew? Is she good at riding?
是的。事实上，这位朝臣说她像一个40岁的女人一样聪明。所以非常、非常令人印象深刻。从这一点开始，你知道，亨利足够感兴趣，他想要定期了解伊丽莎白的进展。这不仅是她作为学者的进展，也是她作为音乐家的能力，这对亨利来说很重要。你知道，她会跳舞吗？她会缝纫吗？她擅长骑马吗？
Can she hawk? And actually, she's good at all these things. I mean, this is one thing about the Tudors that perhaps, because they're ubiquitous and because they're always the subjects of kind of Channel 5 documentaries and stuff, therefore people are a little bit sick of them. Sort of man for man, woman for woman, they are extremely impressive. They are surely the most proficient and impressive dynasty in English history. I mean, the reason they've got the throne as usurpers as parvenus is because they are very canny, bright, talented, ambitious, driven people. You know, the Tudors don't produce a waste rule. No, and they just seem to be good at everything.
她会放鹰吗？事实上，她擅长所有这些事情。我的意思是，关于都铎王朝有一点，也许是因为他们无处不在，而且总是第五频道纪录片之类的主题，所以人们有点厌倦了他们。但无论男女，他们都非常令人印象深刻。他们肯定是英国历史上最精通、最令人印象深刻的王朝。我的意思是，他们之所以作为篡位者、暴发户获得王位，是因为他们是非常精明、聪明、有才华、有野心、有干劲的人。你知道，都铎王朝没有产生过废物。不，他们似乎什么都擅长。
Yeah. Elizabeth sounds an absolute prodigy, but clearly people are amazingly impressed by her. And Henry is sufficiently impressed that by 1543, he's decided, okay, I'm going to rehabilitate her. You know, I like the sound of her. She sounds like she might be a credit to me. And this is a really key moment in Elizabeth's life because, you know, for as long as she can remember, Henry has been this distant, terrifying figure, the man who had executed her mother. She hadn't seen him.
是的。伊丽莎白听起来绝对是个神童，但很明显人们对她印象深刻。亨利印象深刻，以至于到1543年，他决定，好吧，我要恢复她的地位。你知道，我喜欢她的名声。她听起来可能是我的一份荣誉。这是伊丽莎白生命中一个非常关键的时刻，因为，你知道，只要她有记忆以来，亨利一直是一个遥远、可怕的人物，那个处决了她母亲的男人。她没见过他。
she's been literally banished from his presence. And of course, she's also aware that it's due to her father's ruling that she's inferior in rank to Mary as well as to Edward. And I think also something else that must be slightly destabilizing to Elizabeth emotionally, but also complicate her attitude to Henry is the fact that he just keeps burning through stepmothers. So Jane dies. Then he marries Anna Cleves, designs he doesn't want her and dumps her. Then he marries Catherine Howard and Catherine Howard ends up having her head chopped off on charges of adultery just as Anne had done. So I think that must be very traumatic for Elizabeth. But fortunately for her, once Henry allows her back into his life, she does impress him. He does think this girl is
她实际上被逐出了他的视线。当然，她也意识到，正是由于她父亲的裁决，她在地位上才低于玛丽和爱德华。而且我认为还有另一件事，对伊丽莎白的情感来说可能稍微有些不稳定，但也使她对亨利的态度复杂化，那就是他不断地更换继母。简去世了。然后他娶了安妮·克莱夫斯，设计他不想要她并抛弃了她。然后他娶了凯瑟琳·霍华德，凯瑟琳·霍华德最终像安妮一样，因通奸罪被砍了头。所以我认为这对伊丽莎白来说一定非常痛苦。但幸运的是，一旦亨利允许她回到他的生活中，她确实打动了他。他确实认为这个女孩
really quite something. And I think partly that's because she's very smart, but it's also because she really looks like him. No, she's got auburn hair, she's got fair skin. I mean, fortunately, she's not enormously fat, which would have been awful, but she looks like a Tudor. You know, she is her father's daughter. She's very clearly been welcomed back into the fault, as has Mary. So when he marries Catherine Parr, so that's wedding number six, all three of the children are there, Edward, Mary, and Elizabeth. Yeah.
真的很特别。我认为部分原因是她非常聪明，但也因为她看起来真的很像他。不，她有赤褐色的头发，她有白皙的皮肤。我的意思是，幸运的是，她没有胖得离谱，那会很糟糕，但她看起来像个都铎人。你知道，她是她父亲的女儿。她很明显被欢迎回到了家庭，玛丽也是。所以当他娶凯瑟琳·帕尔时，也就是第六次婚礼，三个孩子都在场，爱德华、玛丽和伊丽莎白。是的。
And she's still a bastard, right? I mean, Henry has not, will never withdraw that. Yeah. So this act of parliament establishes that Edward will succeed him. if Edward has no children then Mary will become queen and if Mary then dies without children then Elizabeth will become queen but with kind of absolute typical inconsistency Henry does not repeal the acts of bastardy
而且她仍然是个私生女，对吧？我的意思是，亨利没有，永远不会撤销这一点。是的。所以这项议会法案规定爱德华将继承他。如果爱德华没有孩子，那么玛丽将成为女王，如果玛丽死后没有孩子，那么伊丽莎白将成为女王，但亨利以一种典型的、完全不一致的方式，没有废除私生子法案。
so this is going to be an issue for both Mary and Elizabeth throughout their reigns essentially but I think at the time the fact that Elizabeth has been reinstated in the line of succession she sees it as a mark of Henry's love for her And people may wonder, well, what is Elizabeth's attitude to Henry, this guy who had killed her mother? So David Starkey puts it, her memory of her father formed in these few years of the mid-1540s, was a benign one. For Elizabeth, he was not a wife murdering monster, but a loving parent, a formidable ruler, and model to which she aspired. I think that's largely true, but I think it must also obviously be seasoned with a certain sense of dread.
所以这基本上将成为玛丽和伊丽莎白在她们统治期间的一个问题，但我认为在当时，伊丽莎白被恢复到继承顺序中，她将其视为亨利爱她的标志。人们可能会想，那么伊丽莎白对亨利这个杀了她母亲的男人是什么态度？正如大卫·斯塔基所说，她对父亲的记忆是在1540年代中期的这几年里形成的，是一个良性的记忆。对于伊丽莎白来说，他不是一个杀妻狂魔，而是一个慈爱的父亲、一位令人生畏的统治者，以及她所向往的榜样。我认为这在很大程度上是真的，但我认为它显然也必须夹杂着某种恐惧感。
But you can dread someone and still want their approval. Totally. Cray their approval. I mean, even when he's in his sort of fat phase, he's still a very magnetic and charismatic personality. And a little girl, we're talking about when she's 8, 9, 10 or something. You know, he's the king. He's the son around whom everybody else revolves. Of course, she'd be drawn to him and impressed.
但你可以畏惧某人，同时仍然渴望他们的认可。完全是。渴望他们的认可。我的意思是，即使在他那种肥胖阶段，他仍然是一个非常有磁性和魅力的人。一个小女孩，我们说的是她8、9、10岁左右的时候。你知道，他是国王。他是每个人都围绕着旋转的太阳。当然，她会被他吸引并留下深刻印象。
And she'd be, if nothing else, awed by his magnificence and by the fear that he inspires and other people. Yeah. So Henry's definitely influenced, but I think a much bigger influence on Elizabeth is her new stepmother, Catherine Parr, so the new queen, who, a bit like Anne Boleyn or Jane Seymour, not from a tremendously distinguished background. She's the daughter of a knight from Cumbria. But she's clever. She's very cultured, very sexy, even though she's in her early 30s, with apologies to women who are in their early 30s. Even though, Tom. Even though. I'm repeating the standards of the age. Early 30s was. quite old by Tudor standards. She's also an evangelical, so that's a slight issue, because by this point, Henry is kind of reverting to pretty much a Catholic identity, but that's fine. Catherine keeps that secret. But there's another thing that she also keeps secret, which is that she is in love with
而且，如果不是别的，她会被他的宏伟以及他激发他人恐惧的能力所敬畏。是的。所以亨利绝对有影响，但我认为对伊丽莎白影响更大的是她的新继母凯瑟琳·帕尔，也就是新王后，她有点像安妮·博林或简·西摩，出身并不显赫。她是坎布里亚一位骑士的女儿。但她很聪明。她非常有教养，非常性感，尽管她已经30出头了，向30出头的女性道歉。尽管如此，汤姆。尽管如此。我是在重复那个时代的标准。30出头在都铎时代已经相当老了。她也是一位福音派信徒，所以这是一个小问题，因为到这个时候，亨利正在某种程度上回归到几乎是天主教的身份，但这没关系。凯瑟琳保守了这个秘密。但她还保守了另一件事，那就是她爱上了
another man. And this other man is the brother of Henry's late wife, Jane Seymour, Thomas Seymour. and obviously Catherine Power does not need to be told that this is a very dangerous thing for any queen to be involved with and all the more so because Thomas Seymour is very charismatic, very good looking so he's described as being fierce and courage
另一个男人。这个男人是亨利已故妻子简·西摩的兄弟，托马斯·西摩。显然，凯瑟琳·帕尔不需要被告知，对于任何王后来说，这都是一件非常危险的事情，更何况托马斯·西摩非常有魅力，非常英俊，所以他被描述为勇敢、
courtly in fashion in personage, stately he has an astonishingly long beard and of course also he is not morbidly obese and he doesn't have a weeping sore on his leg both of which attributes Henry by this point does have. But still, there's no way that Catherine is going to carry on with Thomas Seymour. So she encourages him to go off to war in France, where he fights very bravely with Henry in a campaign that culminates in the capture of Boulogne. And meanwhile, back in England,
举止优雅，风度翩翩，他有一把惊人的长胡子，当然他也没有病态肥胖，腿上也没有流脓的疮，而亨利到这个时候都有这些特征。但即便如此，凯瑟琳也不可能和托马斯·西摩继续下去。所以她鼓励他去法国参战，在那里他与亨利并肩作战，在最终夺取布洛涅的战役中表现得非常勇敢。与此同时，在英国，
Catherine is ruling as regent, which she does very well, rather as Catherine of Aragon had done all those decades before. And again, this must be quite a formative influence, I think, on both Mary and Elizabeth, because it's a demonstration that women can govern the kingdom effectively and well. And that must serve as a kind of inspiration for them, I think, later in life. Yeah. And Elizabeth particularly ends up devoted to Catherine, who takes her duties as stepmother very seriously. Catherine is an impressive person. She's smart and she's, you know, poised. But she's also canny. I mean, the whole thing with Thomas Seymour, she doesn't make the mistake that Catherine Howard made, for example. She's also very stylish.
凯瑟琳以摄政王的身份统治，她做得非常好，就像几十年前阿拉贡的凯瑟琳所做的那样。同样，我认为这对玛丽和伊丽莎白来说一定是一个相当具有形成性的影响，因为它证明了女性可以有效且出色地治理王国。我认为这在她们以后的生活中一定是一种灵感。是的。尤其是伊丽莎白最终对凯瑟琳非常忠诚，凯瑟琳非常认真地对待她作为继母的职责。凯瑟琳是一个令人印象深刻的人。她很聪明，而且，你知道，从容不迫。但她也很精明。我的意思是，关于托马斯·西摩的整件事，她没有犯凯瑟琳·霍华德那样的错误。她也非常时尚。
I mean, like Anne Boleyn, she loves her fashion, and just as Anne Boleyn had done, she understands that a queen has to look like a queen. And so I think all in all, she becomes a huge influence on Elizabeth, who she keeps fixing her attentions on would-be stepmothers, and they keep vanishing. And now she feels, well, at last, I've got one that, you know, that's a keeper. And this matters because Catherine becomes stepmother at a crucial point in Elizabeth's intellectual development. And you've said Catherine Parr is a very kind of smart woman. She takes a great interest in Elizabeth's education, because by this point, Elizabeth has outgrown Kate's ability to teach her. Unfortunately, this doesn't matter because Elizabeth, by this point, is growing up alongside her younger brother, Edward. And because Edward is going to become a king, inevitably he has the best teachers in the country at his service.
我的意思是，像安妮·博林一样，她热爱时尚，就像安妮·博林所做的那样，她明白王后必须看起来像个王后。所以我认为总而言之，她对伊丽莎白产生了巨大的影响，伊丽莎白一直把注意力集中在未来的继母身上，而她们却不断消失。现在她觉得，好吧，终于，我找到了一个，你知道，一个可以留住的人。这很重要，因为凯瑟琳在伊丽莎白智力发展的关键时刻成为了继母。你说凯瑟琳·帕尔是一个非常聪明的女人。她对伊丽莎白的教育非常感兴趣，因为到这个时候，伊丽莎白已经超出了凯特教导她的能力。不幸的是，这并不重要，因为伊丽莎白到这个时候正和她的弟弟爱德华一起长大。因为爱德华将成为国王，不可避免地，他拥有全国最好的老师为他服务。
And so Catherine convinces Henry that Elizabeth should have use of these teachers as well. Edward is smart. He's a Tudor, but Elizabeth is much smarter. Everyone recognizes that. And so by the time she's 10, she's the focus of this kind of really brilliant circle. It's characterized by humanist scholarship and by evangelical religion. So kind of what we might start to call Protestantism. And the key figure is a guy called William Grindle, who is a young scholar from St. John's Cambridge, and he teaches both Latin and Greek. And the emphasis on Greek is very, very of the moment. So Henry only had the most rudimentary Greek. Mary had no Greek. Elizabeth is getting the kind of the latest in educational fashion. And Elizabeth develops a profound emotional as well as intellectual bond with Grindle. And I think it intensifies her sense of loyalty to Catherine as well, because it's Catherine who seems to have found her, Grindle, to be her teacher.
所以凯瑟琳说服亨利，伊丽莎白也应该有这些老师。爱德华很聪明。他是都铎人，但伊丽莎白更聪明。每个人都承认这一点。所以到她10岁时，她成为了这个非常出色的圈子的焦点。它的特点是人文主义学术和福音派宗教。所以有点像我们可能开始称之为新教的东西。关键人物是一个叫威廉·格林德尔的人，他是剑桥圣约翰学院的一位年轻学者，他教授拉丁语和希腊语。对希腊语的强调非常、非常符合当时的潮流。所以亨利只有最基础的希腊语。玛丽没有希腊语。伊丽莎白正在接受最新的教育时尚。伊丽莎白与格林德尔建立了深厚的情感和智力纽带。我认为这也加强了她对凯瑟琳的忠诚，因为正是凯瑟琳似乎找到了她，格林德尔，来做她的老师。
There's further kind of emotional churn because, listen, to our previous episode may remember that Anne Boleyn had as her private chaplain a man called Matthew Parker. And in her last interview with him before she got taken to the tower, she had asked Matthew Parker to look out for Elizabeth. And this is what Matthew Parker is now doing. He's coming and giving sermons to Elizabeth and instructing her and all kinds of things. So that is, I think, intensifying what must for Elizabeth be a very emotional as well as intellectual sense of loyalties, that it is tied up with her mother. It's tied up with Catherine Parr, her stepmother. There's kind of love as well as religion and education as part of the swirl.
还有进一步的情感波动，因为，听着，我们上一集节目的听众可能记得，安妮·博林有一位叫马修·帕克的私人牧师。在她被带到塔楼之前的最后一次谈话中，她曾请求马修·帕克照顾伊丽莎白。这就是马修·帕克现在正在做的事情。他来给伊丽莎白讲道，指导她各种事情。所以我认为，这加强了伊丽莎白内心深处的情感和智力忠诚感，它与她的母亲联系在一起。它与她的继母凯瑟琳·帕尔联系在一起。爱、宗教和教育是漩涡的一部分。
So you don't think there's any doubt whatsoever that Elizabeth grows up a strong believer in the newly fashionable. Let's just call it Protestantism. I think so. And I think the big influence on her is Catherine Parr. Okay. Interesting. And Catherine Parr, she's from a generation where a kind of hard Protestant identity hasn't yet evolved, but that's clearly the direction of travel. And I think you can see how this is affecting Elizabeth emotionally from two New Year gifts that she makes. First, she makes and gives to Catherine Parr in 1545, and then the second the following year is to Henry himself. So the first, the one that she gives to the Queen, this is a translation from French of a poem by Marguerite of Navarre.
所以你不认为伊丽莎白成长为一个坚定的新教徒（让我们称之为新教）有什么疑问吗？我想是这样。我认为对她影响最大的是凯瑟琳·帕尔。好吧。有趣。凯瑟琳·帕尔，她来自一个强硬的新教身份尚未演变出来的时代，但这显然是发展的方向。我认为你可以从她制作的两份新年礼物中看出这对伊丽莎白的情感影响。首先，她在1545年制作并送给凯瑟琳·帕尔，然后第二年送给亨利本人。所以第一份，送给王后的那份，这是从法语翻译的纳瓦拉的玛格丽特的诗。
And people may remember that Marguerite of Navarre had been the patron of Anne. Berlin, Elizabeth's mother. And it's very evangelical in tone. So again, that mingling of emotional loyalty with kind of proto-Protestantism. It's all there. And then the second, the one that Elizabeth presents to Henry, this is a translation of Catherine's own prayers and meditations, which she'd written in English. And Elizabeth has translated into French, into Italian, and into Latin. And at the point where she does this, she is 12 years old. So, you know, it's her first year at secondary school. I mean, it's unbelievably impressive.
人们可能记得纳瓦拉的玛格丽特曾是伊丽莎白母亲安妮·博林的赞助人。它的基调非常福音派。所以再次，那种情感忠诚与原始新教的融合。一切都在那里。然后第二份，伊丽莎白送给亨利的那份，这是凯瑟琳自己的祈祷和冥想的翻译，她是用英语写的。伊丽莎白把它翻译成了法语、意大利语和拉丁语。在她做这件事的时候，她12岁。所以，你知道，这是她上中学的头一年。我的意思是，这令人难以置信地印象深刻。
How standards have fallen, Tom. Yeah, how standards are fallen. And what's more, she's embroidered the cover. So she's kind of, she's made the binding as well and embroidered it with, with Tudor roses. And she dedicates it to the most illustrious and most mighty King Henry VIII, Elizabeth, His Majesty's the most humbled daughter, wishes all happiness and begs his blessing. Wow. And this is tribute not just to her father, but to her stepmother as well.
标准下降了多少，汤姆。是的，标准下降了多少。而且更重要的是，她绣了封面。所以她，她也制作了装订，并用都铎玫瑰绣了它。她把它献给最杰出、最强大的亨利八世国王，伊丽莎白，陛下最谦卑的女儿，祝愿一切幸福并祈求他的祝福。哇。这不仅是对她父亲的致敬，也是对她继母的致敬。
And so when Henry dies, which he does on the 28th of January, 1547, so that's a year after Elizabeth had made that gift. And he succeeded by Edward VI, who by this point is nine years old, so still just a boy. To be fair, to him, he's very bright in his own right. Yeah, he's very bright as well. But I think he's not as brilliant as Elizabeth is. Okay. And so Elizabeth, she now turns to Catherine Parr to basically provide her with her home.
所以当亨利去世时，也就是1547年1月28日，那是伊丽莎白送出那份礼物的一年后。爱德华六世继位，他当时九岁，所以还是个男孩。公平地说，他自己也非常聪明。是的，他也非常聪明。但我认为他没有伊丽莎白那么出色。好吧。所以伊丽莎白，她现在转向凯瑟琳·帕尔，基本上为她提供家。
And so a few weeks after Henry's died, Elizabeth moves to Chelsea, where the widow queen has moved into one of the queen's manor houses. It's a very lovely spot. It's got pipe water. It's got cherry and peach trees, herb gardens, lots of, you know, haynony knowing, all that kind of stuff. And with Elizabeth goes her beloved lady mistress, Kate, who is now, she's just got. married, so she's now known as Kate Ashley or Astley. Elizabeth also has in her train her new cofferer, her kind of business manager, the guy who looks after her accounts.
所以亨利去世几周后，伊丽莎白搬到了切尔西，寡妇王后搬进了王后的庄园之一。这是一个非常可爱的地方。它有管道供水。它有樱桃树和桃树，药草园，很多，你知道，海诺尼知道，所有那些东西。和伊丽莎白一起去的是她心爱的女管家凯特，她现在，她刚结婚，所以她现在被称为凯特·阿什利或阿斯特利。伊丽莎白身边还有她的新出纳，她的业务经理，负责照顾她账目的人。
And this is a man called Thomas Parry. And we have lots of Welsh listeners who complain that we don't have enough Welsh figures, Welsh characters in our podcast. So I will read you the description that Starkey gives of Thomas Parry that he was a fat, self-satisfied Welshman. Oh, no, that's great. So it's very clear what David Starkey thinks of Welshman from that quote. And also, he's not very good at maths, so that doesn't make him a very competent coffer. So he's useless, he's fat. He's useless, but he is Welsh.
这个人叫托马斯·帕里。我们有很多威尔士听众抱怨我们的播客里没有足够的威尔士人物、威尔士角色。所以我将读给你听斯塔基对托马斯·帕里的描述，他是一个肥胖、自以为是的威尔士人。哦，不，那太棒了。所以从那句话中可以很清楚地看出大卫·斯塔基对威尔士人的看法。而且，他的数学不太好，所以这使他不是一个非常称职的出纳。所以他没用，他很胖。他没用，但他是个威尔士人。
So there's one positive. Oh, and also another positive from Elizabeth's point of view, you know, he's a Protestant. Yeah. And he's exceptionally loyal to her. You know, we like to do Welsh history every now and again, don't we? And we've done it now. So that's brilliant. We've done it for the year.
所以有一个积极的一面。哦，还有从伊丽莎白的角度来看的另一个积极的一面，你知道，他是个新教徒。是的。而且他对她非常忠诚。你知道，我们喜欢时不时地做威尔士历史，不是吗？我们现在已经做了。所以这太棒了。我们今年已经做过了。
That's it for the year, yeah. So Elizabeth, Kate, the fat, self-satisfied Welshman, they're all hanging out with Catherine Parr in this gorgeous house in Chelsea. The vibe is very scholarly, it's very sober, it's very evangelical, and it's much more openly evangelical than it had been under Henry VIII. Henry VIII hadn't really proved of kind of radical evangelical. Yeah, yeah. But under Edward the 6th, the Reformation has been absolutely turbocharged, you know.
这一年就这样结束了。伊丽莎白、凯特，还有那个肥胖、自以为是的威尔士人，他们都和凯瑟琳·帕尔一起待在切尔西那栋华丽的房子里。那里的氛围非常学术，非常严肃，非常福音派，而且比亨利八世时期更加公开地倾向福音派。亨利八世其实并不赞同那种激进的福音派。是的，确实。但在爱德华六世统治下，宗教改革绝对是加足了马力。
Yeah, get out the whitewash. Yeah, get rid of the saints. Let's go down the rude screens. Let's go for it. But it has to be said that Catherine Parr's house isn't all God. It's not all ancient Greek. Because in the spring of 1547, so this is only a few months after the death of Henry VIII, there is a completely bombshell development.
没错，把石灰水拿出来吧。把圣像都清理掉。让我们把圣坛屏风也拆了。大干一场吧。但必须得说，凯瑟琳·帕尔的家里并不全是上帝，也不全是古希腊语。因为在1547年春天，也就是亨利八世去世仅仅几个月后，发生了一件彻底的重磅事件。
Catherine Parr, Henry's widow, the late queen, clandestinely marries her old flame, the long-bearded Uber lad, Thomas Seymour. The Mr. Tickle of Tudor politics. The Mr. Tickle. And he by now has become a very, very big cheese because his brother, Edward, has become both the Duke of Somerset and the Lord Protector. And Thomas himself has become the Lord High Admiral, because of course, both of them
亨利的遗孀、已故王后凯瑟琳·帕尔，秘密嫁给了她的旧情人，那个留着长胡子的超级潮男托马斯·西摩。他是都铎政治圈里的“挠痒痒先生”。就是那位“挠痒痒先生”。此时他已经成了个大人物，因为他的哥哥爱德华已经成为了萨默塞特公爵和护国公。而托马斯本人也成了海军大臣，因为当然，他们俩
are the uncles of the young king, Edward VI. So for Thomas Seymour to marry a late queen, it's a punchy thing to do. Because, I know, he's massively punching above his weight there. And so when the news breaks, there is outrage at court. Mary, Elizabeth's elder sister, is outraged, breaks off relations with her stepmother completely, demands that Elizabeth do the same. But Elizabeth doesn't. And the consequences of this, you called Thomas Seymour, Mr. Tickle.
都是年轻国王爱德华六世的叔叔。所以对于托马斯·西摩来说，娶一位已故王后是一件很大胆的事。因为我知道，他这完全是越级挑战。所以当消息传出时，朝廷一片哗然。伊丽莎白的姐姐玛丽感到非常愤怒，彻底断绝了与继母的关系，并要求伊丽莎白也这样做。但伊丽莎白没有。而这件事的后果，你刚才称托马斯·西摩为“挠痒痒先生”。
Well, let's say that the consequence of this is that the tickle hands can start tickling. Yeah, well, come back after the break to find out what happens. with Thomas Seymour's busy hands. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered.
好吧，我们就说这件事的后果就是那些“挠痒痒”的手可以开始行动了。是的，休息之后回来，我们再来看看托马斯·西摩那双忙碌的手会发生什么。本期节目由Uber赞助。现在，你知道那种在最需要的时候有人挺身而出的感觉吗？我们有时都需要这种支持，而Uber深知这一点。Uber不仅仅是打车或送餐。
It's showing up no matter what. Like for your long-distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters. Whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. Hello, welcome back to the rest is history. So we are in England in 1548. We are a year in to the reign of the ultra-protestant, very precocious Edward the 6th, and specifically we are in Seymour Place, which is the home of Edward's uncle,
它意味着无论如何都会出现。就像为你远方的朋友送去生病时的热汤，在他们低落时送去鲜花。在真正重要的时刻。无论是什么，你都会出现。有志者，事竟成，我们正在路上。Uber，我们在路上。立即下载应用程序。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。现在是1548年的英国。我们正处于极度新教、早熟的爱德华六世统治的第一年，具体来说，我们是在西摩府邸，也就是爱德华叔叔的家，
Thomas Seymour, who you may remember, has married Edward's stepmother, Catherine Parr, the widow of Henry VIII. And Catherine Parr is pregnant, and here we are, all sweetness and light, because her stepdaughter, the teenage Lady Elizabeth, 14 years old, has just arrived at the house, having been away for the festive season. So there's another girl there actually, who we've had on the rest of history before, who's another very clever girl, another girl with aristocratic lineage, another girl who loves a bit of Latin and a bit of Greek, and loves Protestantism. And this is somebody called Lady Jane Grey, who's only 11 years old.
托马斯·西摩的家。你可能还记得，他娶了爱德华的继母凯瑟琳·帕尔，也就是亨利八世的遗孀。凯瑟琳·帕尔怀孕了，这里一片祥和，因为她的继女，十几岁的伊丽莎白女勋爵，14岁，刚刚结束节日假期回到家中。其实那里还有另一个女孩，我们之前在《历史的余味》中提到过，她也是个非常聪明的女孩，有着贵族血统，喜欢拉丁语和希腊语，也热爱新教。她就是简·格雷女勋爵，当时只有11岁。
She's 11 years old, and she's Thomas Seymour's Ward, and she's Elizabeth's cousin. And as you said, Dominic, we did a couple of episodes of... on Lady Jane Gray. And people who want to listen to those episodes, they are 293 and 294. Now, Dominic, you said that all is sweetness and light at Seymour Place in London. I'm not actually sure that's quite true. It's just a figure of speech, Tom. I'm just setting the scene.
她才11岁，是托马斯·西摩的被监护人，也是伊丽莎白的表亲。正如你所说，多米尼克，我们做过几期关于简·格雷的节目。想听这些节目的听众，可以去听第293和294期。现在，多米尼克，你说伦敦的西摩府邸一片祥和。我其实不太确定那是真的。那只是个比喻，汤姆。我只是在铺陈背景。
Sometimes there's tears behind the smiles. Well, I mean, you know, at Christmas, there are always a dark undertow. Yeah. So, for starters, Elizabeth is yet again in a state of bereavement because William Grindle, her beloved teacher, had died a few weeks before. It's not all bad because just a few days before arriving at Seymour Place, she'd received a letter from Grindle's own teacher, the great educationalist, Roger Asham, offering to take Grindle's place.
有时笑容背后会有泪水。嗯，我的意思是，你知道，圣诞节期间总会有暗流涌动。是的。首先，伊丽莎白又一次陷入了丧亲之痛，因为她敬爱的老师威廉·格林德尔在几周前去世了。不过也不全是坏事，因为在到达西摩府邸的前几天，她收到了格林德尔的老师、伟大的教育家罗杰·阿斯坎的来信，主动提出接替格林德尔的位置。
And Elizabeth completely leaps at the chance. I mean, it's an amazing opportunity for her because Asham is the most famous, the most brilliant scholar in England. And Asham promises that he will finessell Elizabeth's education, but also that he will look out for her. So he writes, I shall think it my greatest happiness, if the time ever comes when my services can be of use to you. And I think these words would have had great resonance for Elizabeth
伊丽莎白完全抓住了这个机会。我的意思是，这对她来说是一个绝佳的机会，因为阿斯坎是英国最著名、最杰出的学者。阿斯坎承诺他不仅会精进伊丽莎白的学业，还会照顾她。他写道：“如果有一天我的服务能对您有所帮助，我将认为这是我最大的幸福。”我想这些话对伊丽莎白来说一定产生了巨大的共鸣，
because actually her circumstances and seem or place, no matter how devoted she is to Catherine Parr, her stepmother, are actually not easy at all. So firstly, you mentioned Catherine's pregnant. It's the first time she's been pregnant. I think this is probably a bit destabilising for an orphaned girl who up to this point had been the sole focus of her stepmother's attentions. And perhaps worries about being supplanted.
因为实际上她在西摩府邸的处境，无论她对继母凯瑟琳·帕尔多么忠诚，其实一点也不轻松。首先，你提到凯瑟琳怀孕了。这是她第一次怀孕。我想这对一个孤儿来说可能有点动摇，因为在此之前，她一直是继母关注的焦点。她可能担心自己会被取代。
yet again. Yeah, I think so. But that, Dominic, is not the main reason why there is an atmosphere in Seymour Place. The main reason is because of the long-bearded, ludicrously ambitious, top lad, Thomas Seymour. So Thomas Seymour is the younger brother of the Duke of Somerset, who's the Lord Protector, and he's resentful of this. It's kind of classic, kind of Prince Harry dynamic, you know, resentful of the elder brother wants him out the way. He's kind of on maneuvers plotting to try and supplant his elder brother. So maybe there's a kind of slight degree of mood of anxiety in Seymour plays for that reason. But there's a much more immediate personal reason for Elizabeth to be uncomfortable in Thomas Seymour's presence. And that is basically that for the past few months, Thomas Seymour has had the key. to Elizabeth's bedroom and basically every morning he's got into the habit of walking into her bedroom. And it's reported later that if Elizabeth was up and in the process of getting dressed,
又一次。是的，我想是这样。但多米尼克，那并不是西摩府邸气氛压抑的主要原因。主要原因是那个留着长胡子、野心勃勃、顶级潮男托马斯·西摩。托马斯·西摩是护国公萨默塞特公爵的弟弟，他对此心怀不满。这有点像经典的哈里王子式的动态，你知道，对哥哥心怀怨恨，想把他踢开。他一直在搞小动作，密谋试图取代他的哥哥。所以也许西摩府邸确实因为这个原因有一种焦虑的氛围。但伊丽莎白在托马斯·西摩面前感到不舒服，还有一个更直接的个人原因。那就是在过去几个月里，托马斯·西摩一直拿着伊丽莎白卧室的钥匙，而且基本上每天早上他都养成了走进她卧室的习惯。据后来报道，如果伊丽莎白起床正在穿衣服，
he would come up and strike her up on the back or on the buttocks. If she was still in bed, he'd pull back the curtains, you know, that veil her, the four poster beds, as though he would come at her and Elizabeth would shrink back, cower beneath the sheets. On one occasion, it's supported, he tries to force a kiss. Kate goes and confronts him about this, and he shows no kind of embarrassment about this, but instead explodes in rage. I will tell my lord protector how I am slanded, and I will not leave off, for I mean no evil. I can do what I like. Yeah, just a friendly kiss. Just a bit of fun. Yeah. People may want to award about Catherine. You know, is she becoming suspicious? I think she is to a degree, but he does not reign in his behavior at all. And actually,
他就会走过来拍她的背或臀部。如果她还在床上，他就会拉开帷幕，你知道，遮住四柱床的那种帘子，好像他要冲向她，而伊丽莎白会退缩，躲在被子里。有一次，据称他试图强吻她。凯特去质问他这件事，他对此毫无尴尬，反而勃然大怒。我会告诉护国公我是如何被诽谤的，我不会停止，因为我没有恶意。我想做什么就做什么。是的，只是一个友好的吻。只是开个玩笑。是的。人们可能会担心凯瑟琳。你知道，她开始怀疑了吗？我想她在一定程度上是怀疑的，但他根本没有收敛自己的行为。而且实际上，
It all gets a bit weird with Thomas Seymour and Catherine and Elizabeth. So there's one very bizarre occasion when Catherine and Elizabeth are out walking in the garden. And Thomas surprises them and he cuts Elizabeth's gown, and I quote, in an hundred pieces. What's kind of more bizarre still is that according to Elizabeth, the queen held her while the Lord Admiral cut it. So it's quite odd, isn't it? That is pretty weird. What's Catherine Parr thinking during all this? One theory is that maybe it was a bet, a bit of fun.
托马斯·西摩、凯瑟琳和伊丽莎白之间的一切变得有点奇怪。有一次非常离奇的情况，凯瑟琳和伊丽莎白在花园里散步。托马斯突然出现，他把伊丽莎白的礼服剪成了，我引用一下，“一百片”。更离奇的是，据伊丽莎白说，王后在海军大臣剪衣服时还按住了她。所以这很奇怪，不是吗？那确实很奇怪。凯瑟琳·帕尔在这一切过程中在想什么？一种理论是，也许这只是个赌注，一点小乐趣。
I think Catherine wants to believe that, that it's just innocent fun. But I think that in the build-up to, you know, the Christmas break, I think she's clearly hoping that if Elizabeth goes away, maybe when she comes back, everything will be sorted out, and Thomas Seymour will be keeping his hands in his pockets. The problem is that's not what happens. So the moment Elizabeth is back, Seymour is up to his old tricks, coming to her bedroom each morning,
我想凯瑟琳想相信这一点，相信这只是无辜的乐趣。但我认为在圣诞假期临近时，她显然希望如果伊丽莎白离开，也许等她回来时，一切都会解决，托马斯·西摩会把手放在自己的口袋里。问题是事情并没有那样发展。所以伊丽莎白一回来，西摩又开始耍他的老把戏，每天早上穿着睡袍、光着腿、趿拉着拖鞋走进她的卧室，
in his nightgown bare-legged in his slippers and Elizabeth by now has developed strategy which is that if he bursts in on her she reaches for a book and puts her nose in the book yeah hoping that the sight of some Greek verses or something will keep him at bay yeah exactly cat she upbraids Seymour again again it has no effect and then that spring the crisis point which was kind of always going to
而伊丽莎白此时已经制定了一个策略，那就是如果他闯进来，她就伸手拿一本书，把鼻子埋进书里，是的，希望看到一些希腊诗句之类的东西能让他退避三舍。是的，没错。凯特再次责备西摩，但依然没有任何效果。然后那个春天，那个注定要到来的危机点，
arrive does finally arrive because Catherine again to quote came suddenly upon them where they were all alone he having her in his arms. He having her in his arms is ambiguous, though, isn't it? Because they're alone together, you know, in an embrace. Is that voluntary or is that involuntary? It's not clear. It's unclear.
终于到来了，因为凯瑟琳再次，引用一下，“突然出现在他们面前，当时他们正独自在一起，他把她抱在怀里。”他把她抱在怀里，这很暧昧，不是吗？因为他们独自在一起，你知道，在拥抱中。那是自愿的还是非自愿的？不清楚。不清楚。
And I think it's unclear to Catherine. Right. And she is very heavily pregnant by this point and obviously incredibly upset. And I think that perhaps she fears the worst that Elizabeth has been complicit in this. And so she sends Elizabeth away. Elizabeth goes to a place called Chesson, in Hertfordshire. And there she stays with Kate Astby's sister and her husband, who's a guy called Sir Anthony Denny. And the salient thing about Sir Anthony Denny, the one thing that everybody knows about him and why his service has been so valued by Henry VIII is that he's a courtier chiefly celebrated for his ability to keep a secret.
我想凯瑟琳也不清楚。没错。此时她已经怀孕很深，显然非常难过。我想她可能担心最坏的情况，即伊丽莎白对此是同谋。于是她把伊丽莎白送走了。伊丽莎白去了赫特福德郡一个叫切森的地方。她在那里和凯特·阿什比的妹妹以及她的丈夫住在一起，那个人叫安东尼·丹尼爵士。关于安东尼·丹尼爵士，每个人都知道的一点，也是为什么他的服务如此受到亨利八世重视的原因，就是他是一位以守口如瓶而闻名的朝臣。
And obviously, both Elizabeth and Catherine are paranoid. The gossip may leak, that the story may break. all that summer they're kind of waiting really for the rumours to spread and and actually they seem not to and that's a source of of great relief to both of them and elizabeth and katherine are writing regularly to each other they obviously want to repair their relationship um and katherine writes to elizabeth and says you know if i hear anything bad any story slipping out i will write immediately and let you know right so clearly by this point they are back on side they're their relationship has been patched up.
显然，伊丽莎白和凯瑟琳都很偏执。流言可能会泄露，故事可能会传开。整个夏天，她们都在等待谣言传播，但实际上似乎并没有，这让她们俩都感到非常宽慰。伊丽莎白和凯瑟琳经常写信给对方，她们显然想修复关系。凯瑟琳写信给伊丽莎白说，你知道，如果我听到任何坏消息，任何流言传出来，我会立即写信告诉你。没错，所以很明显，到这个时候，她们已经和好了，她们的关系已经修复了。
But then there's a twist, isn't there? There is a twist, yeah. I mean, you described Catherine of being pregnant. She goes off to one of the Seymour Estates that summer. Soudly Castle, very nice castle, I have to say. And I have to say, I commend it because when I was a boy, they had to my mind, a world leading adventure playground. So that's nice.
但后来出现了一个转折，不是吗？确实有一个转折，是的。我的意思是，你描述了凯瑟琳怀孕的情况。那个夏天她去了西摩家族的一处庄园。苏德利城堡，我必须说，那是一座非常漂亮的城堡。我必须说，我推荐它，因为我小时候，在我看来，那里有一个世界领先的探险游乐场。所以那很不错。
Anyway, she goes to Soudly Castle. She gives birth to a girl called Mary, doesn't she, on the 30th of August? Yeah, he's named after Mary Tudor, interestingly. Oh, that's nice. And then she drops dead. Very sad. So that's the end of Catherine Parr. Yeah, so it's very Jane Seymour. She dies of a postnatal fever. And she's buried two days later in the church at Soudley Castle.
总之，她去了苏德利城堡。她在8月30日生下了一个叫玛丽的女孩，不是吗？是的，有趣的是，她是以玛丽·都铎的名字命名的。哦，那很好。然后她就去世了。非常悲伤。所以这就是凯瑟琳·帕尔的结局。是的，所以这非常像简·西摩。她死于产后热。两天后，她被安葬在苏德利城堡的教堂里。
And it's notable I learnt for two firsts. So the first of these is that I learnt this from Nicola Talas' book on The Young Elizabeth. Catherine Parr is the only English queen to be buried on a private estate. Okay. And I learnt from David Starkey that her funeral was the first Protestant royal funeral. And that very, very devoutly Protestant ward of Sir Thomas Seymour, Lady Jane Gray, plays the role of Chief Moorna. That's interesting. But for Elizabeth, this is another crushing blow.
值得注意的是，我了解到有两个“第一”。第一个是，我从尼古拉·塔拉斯关于《年轻的伊丽莎白》的书中学到的。凯瑟琳·帕尔是唯一一位被安葬在私人庄园的英国王后。好的。我从大卫·斯塔基那里了解到，她的葬礼是第一次新教王室葬礼。而托马斯·西摩爵士那位非常虔诚的新教被监护人，简·格雷女勋爵，担任了首席哀悼者。这很有趣。但对伊丽莎白来说，这是又一次沉重的打击。
I mean, for somebody born into, you know, what you might say, immense privilege and wealth, she's had a really bad run, hasn't she? Basically, everybody that she's got close to has died. Educationalists, mother, father. And lost two stepmothers to childbirth. Yeah. And again, you have to wonder what impact does this have on her? her long-term attitude to the prospects of motherhood. Yeah, of course.
我的意思是，对于一个出生在，你可以说是巨大的特权和财富中的人来说，她的经历真的很糟糕，不是吗？基本上，她亲近的每个人都去世了。教育家、母亲、父亲。还因为分娩失去了两位继母。是的。而且你不得不再次怀疑，这对她有什么影响？她对未来为人母的长期态度。是的，当然。
Not to over-psychologize it again. Although one thing that does occur to me, think about Elizabeth's prospects. So Thomas Seymour, he's very dashing, isn't he? I mean, I know he's something of a mystical, but he's very dashing. He's now a widower, and he would be a bit of a catch, would he not? And Elizabeth is 15 years old and would be a catch in her own right. So is there some possibility that he might? Well, Thomas Seymour, I think, seems.
不要再过度心理分析了。虽然有一件事确实引起了我的注意，想想伊丽莎白的前景。托马斯·西摩，他非常潇洒，不是吗？我的意思是，我知道他有点神秘，但他非常潇洒。他现在是个鳏夫，他会是一个不错的选择，不是吗？而伊丽莎白15岁了，她自己本身也是一个很好的选择。所以有没有可能他会？嗯，托马斯·西摩，我想，似乎
genuinely upset at the loss of his wife. Okay. I think he genuinely loved Catherine and was distraught when she died. But you are right. The fact that she is now dead does mean that he is back on the market and he must be looking at Elizabeth as a very nubile candidate. She is all the more on his mind because by this point he is massively on manoeuvres looking to topple his brother the protector. He has been very much playing the fun uncle with Edward of the sixth. So his elder brother, the Duke of Somerset, is always coming with, you know, issues about problems in Scotland or tax or whatever. Thomas Seymour is turning up with, you know, gifts of money and amusingly spiced cakes, all that kind of thing. What spice would that be that would be so
对失去妻子感到非常难过。好的。我想他确实爱凯瑟琳，在她去世时感到非常痛苦。但你是对的。她现在去世的事实确实意味着他回到了单身市场，他一定在把伊丽莎白视为一个非常年轻的候选人。她更让他挂心，因为此时他正在大规模地搞动作，试图推翻他的哥哥护国公。他一直非常扮演爱德华六世的“有趣叔叔”角色。所以他的哥哥萨默塞特公爵总是带着，你知道，关于苏格兰问题或税收之类的问题来找他。托马斯·西摩却带着，你知道，金钱礼物和有趣的香料蛋糕之类的东西出现。那会是什么香料，竟然会如此
amusing? It would be fun. That's the point. It's fun. Some fun cinnamon. Exactly. And basically, his plan is to seize control of the king physically, and by doing that to force a change of government. And if he can marry Elizabeth, then obviously that would then consolidate his power. He'd be absolutely the power behind the throne. Elizabeth, meanwhile, has left Chesson, where she was hanging out with the very discreet husband of Kate. Anthony Denny. And she's gone back to Hatfield, her childhood home. And here for the first time, she presides over a residence as her own mistress. You know, she is now her own woman. Yeah. And when she's she's travelling from Chescent to Hatfield. She's accompanied by members of Seymour's household,
有趣？那会很有趣。重点就在这里。这很有趣。一些有趣的肉桂。没错。基本上，他的计划是物理上夺取国王的控制权，并通过这种方式强迫政府更迭。如果他能娶到伊丽莎白，那么这显然会巩固他的权力。他将绝对是王权背后的力量。与此同时，伊丽莎白已经离开了切森，她之前和凯特那个非常谨慎的丈夫安东尼·丹尼待在那里。她回到了哈特菲尔德，她童年的家。在这里，她第一次以女主人的身份主持一个住所。你知道，她现在是她自己的主人了。是的。当她从切森前往哈特菲尔德时。她由西摩家的人陪同，
you know, servants of his. And one of them speaks to Kate Ashley, who is obviously riding with Elizabeth, and passes on a message for Elizabeth from Thomas Seymour. I think it suggests that his conversation with Elizabeth may not have been just about ancient Greek, I suspect. Which doesn't reflect terribly well, I think, on Thomas Seymour. And also I don't think it reflects very well on Kate that she's passed it on. And it has to be said that by this point, she's behaving very inappropriately, because people remember that she's been confronting Thomas Seymour when he was married to Catherine. But now Catherine's dead. Kate seems to have completely fallen for him. She seems to have had a bit of a crush on him and has decided that
你知道，他的仆人。其中一个人和凯特·阿什比说话，凯特显然和伊丽莎白一起骑马，并转达了托马斯·西摩给伊丽莎白的信息。我认为这表明他和伊丽莎白的谈话可能不仅仅是关于古希腊语的，我怀疑。这对我来说，对托马斯·西摩的评价不太好。而且我也不认为凯特转达这个消息表现得很好。必须说，到这个时候，她的行为非常不恰当，因为人们记得她曾经在托马斯·西摩娶凯瑟琳时质问过他。但现在凯瑟琳死了。凯特似乎完全迷上了他。她似乎对他有点迷恋，并决定
actually he'd be a great husband for Elizabeth. And so she's kind of endlessly saying to Elizabeth, I really think she'd go for him. And meanwhile, Seymour has also been checking with Thomas Parry, the Welshman for our Welsh listeners about the state of her finances. Yeah. So he's asking, how many persons she kept, what houses she had, what lands. And Thomas Parry, I'm afraid to say, like Kate, has been completely seduced by Seymour's charisma. Basically tells him everything. So essentially, the two people who Elizabeth most trusts, Kate and Parry, are both saying to her, go for it.
实际上他会是伊丽莎白的一个好丈夫。所以她不断地对伊丽莎白说，我真的认为她会选择他。与此同时，西摩也一直在向托马斯·帕里（为我们的威尔士听众介绍一下，他是威尔士人）核实她的财务状况。是的。所以他问，她养了多少人，她有什么房子，什么土地。而托马斯·帕里，我很遗憾地说，像凯特一样，完全被西摩的魅力所诱惑。基本上告诉了他一切。所以本质上，伊丽莎白最信任的两个人，凯特和帕里，都在对她说，去吧。
Yeah. Thomas Seymour himself is sending lewd messages about her buttocks. And so what is Elizabeth herself making of this? And I think looking at the evidence, there is a sense that she is actually tempted. Because one of the reasons why I think Kate does support Seymour's advances is that she has seen that Elizabeth does fancy Seymour. Right. Because you said, I mean, it's important stress. He's very charismatic and good looking, right?
是的。托马斯·西摩本人正在发送关于她臀部的下流信息。那么伊丽莎白自己对此怎么看呢？我认为观察证据，有一种感觉，她实际上是动心了。因为我认为凯特支持西摩的追求的原因之一是，她已经看出伊丽莎白确实看上了西摩。没错。因为正如你所说，我的意思是，强调这一点很重要。他非常有魅力，长得好看，对吧？
Yeah. I mean, he's by all accounts a very, very attractive man. and Kate notes how sometimes she would blush when he was spoken of and it's not unknown for victims of sexual abuse to kind of fall for the person who's abusing them or for teenage girls to have a crush on a much older man right? I mean it's not unknown
是的。我的意思是，据所有人说，他是一个非常非常有吸引力的男人。凯特注意到有时当提到他时，她会脸红，而且性虐待的受害者爱上虐待他们的人，或者十几岁的女孩迷恋一个年长得多的男人，这并不罕见，对吧？我的意思是，这并不罕见。
yeah so to quote David Starkey on this it was an initiation and a brutal one into the world of adult sexuality almost all the men that she subsequently loved or pretended to love resembled Seymour interesting I mean it's very interesting as we will see as we carry the story on. And because of this, because there was an evident partiality on Elizabeth's part towards Seymour, there was gossip that she had surrendered to his advances. So that when
是的，所以引用大卫·斯塔基的话，这是一次启蒙，一次进入成人性世界的残酷启蒙。她后来爱上或假装爱上的几乎所有男人都像西摩。有趣。我的意思是，这非常有趣，正如我们继续讲述这个故事时所看到的那样。正因为如此，因为伊丽莎白对西摩有明显的偏爱，所以有流言说她已经屈服于他的追求。所以当
Catherine Power found Elizabeth in Seymour's arms, the implication was that Elizabeth had welcomed this. And there are some who say that she'd lost her affinity to him. And there are others who say even that she'd had his child. There is no substantive evidence for any of this. And I think that the lack of privacy and to the households being what it was, I think it's most improbable. But there's also another, I think, even more salient reason for rejecting these stories. And that is the evident steelyness, the self-discipline which Elizabeth displays throughout the affair. It is a maturity that is astonishing, I think, in one so young. Because she, unlike Kate, unlike Parry, actually unlike Thomas Seymour himself, completely understands the impossibility of her
凯瑟琳·帕尔在西摩的怀里发现伊丽莎白时，暗示伊丽莎白是欢迎这一点的。有些人说她对他失去了抵抗力。还有人甚至说她怀了他的孩子。没有任何实质性证据支持这些说法。我认为，考虑到家庭的隐私状况，我认为这是最不可能的。但还有一个，我认为，更突出的拒绝这些故事的理由。那就是伊丽莎白在整个事件中表现出的明显的坚定和自律。这是一种成熟，我认为在如此年轻的人身上是令人惊讶的。因为她，不像凯特，不像帕里，实际上不像托马斯·西摩本人，完全理解她
marrying him. And she sums it up completely bluntly. The council will not consent to it. Seymour's plan to marry her. It's not like a kind of private relationship. It touches directly on the affairs of state. And there is no way that any number of vested interests will allow this marriage to go ahead. And so Elizabeth, knowing this and knowing that Seymour is essentially pushing it, has clearly come to an understanding that he's a very intemperate man. And this represents a threat not just to himself, but if she is caught up in his kind of web to her as well. Just a very quick observation, we've mentioned in the last episode that we did a series about Mary Queen of Scots in July, I think it was, this summer. Isn't this the massive contrast
嫁给他的不可能性。她非常直率地总结了这一点。议会是不会同意的。西摩娶她的计划。这不像是一种私人关系。它直接触及国家事务。没有任何既得利益者会允许这桩婚姻继续进行。所以伊丽莎白，知道这一点，并且知道西摩本质上是在推动它，显然已经明白他是一个非常冲动的人。这不仅对他自己构成了威胁，如果她被卷入他的那种网络中，对她也是一种威胁。只是一个非常简短的观察，我们在上一集中提到，我们今年夏天，我想是在七月，做了一个关于苏格兰玛丽女王的系列节目。这难道不是巨大的对比吗？
between these two characters who are so often opposed to each other? The Mary Queen of Scots again and again in this situation always goes with her heart. She makes poor political choices because she can never step back from her own desires, as it were. And Elizabeth, the thing that marks her out is that she always has that kind of sliver of ice and that very political brain, even when she's, what, 15 years old or whatever she is, she's thinking strategically and she's sensible and she's weighing up the odds and all of this kind of thing. which means he doesn't make mistakes. And also what you see in this business, perhaps for the first time, is a feature of her character that will run and run and run, which is that she never commits herself to anything.
在这两个经常被对立的角色之间？苏格兰玛丽女王在这种情况下一再总是跟着她的心走。她做出了糟糕的政治选择，因为她永远无法从自己的欲望中退后一步。而伊丽莎白，标志着她的东西是她总是拥有那种冰冷和非常政治化的头脑，即使在她，什么，15岁还是多少岁的时候，她都在战略性地思考，她是理智的，她在权衡利弊，所有这些事情。这意味着她不会犯错。而且你在这一事件中看到的，也许是第一次，是她性格的一个特征，将贯穿始终，那就是她从不承诺任何事情。
So when Kate presses Seymour's suit, she is non-committal according to one version, according to another. Her refusal is absolute. But she is very, very good at playing a dead bat, at not being histrionic in her refusals, at being studdedly ambiguous, and
所以当凯特推动西摩的追求时，根据一个版本，她是模棱两可的，根据另一个版本。她的拒绝是绝对的。但她非常非常擅长打太极，在拒绝时不会歇斯底里，而是坚定地保持模糊，并且
it's just as well, because early in 1549, it all goes tits up for Thomas Seymour. So on the 16th of January, he breaks into the King's private apartments at Whitehall. And unfortunately for him, there's a dog sleeping outside Edward's door,
这很好，因为1549年初，托马斯·西摩的一切都搞砸了。所以1月16日，他闯入了国王在白厅的私人公寓。不幸的是，
and the dog starts barking at him. And so Thomas Seymour draws his sword and runs the dog through. He's the Jeremy Thorpe of Tudor politics. Yeah, or like Anna Denmark, James I'm first's wife, who shot his favorite hunting dog. That's right. Yeah. There's quite a lot of dog murder going on.
有一条狗睡在爱德华的门外，狗开始对他吠叫。所以托马斯·西摩拔出剑，刺穿了那条狗。他是都铎政治圈里的杰里米·索普。是的，或者像詹姆斯一世的妻子安娜·丹麦，她射杀了他最喜欢的猎犬。没错。是的。有很多杀狗事件发生。
Yeah. But this is, I think, is the first major example of it. And so Thomas Seymour then, oh, God, I've killed the King's dog. This isn't going well. And so he just runs. And then the next day he pretends that nothing's happened. And he kind of saunteres around and goes to Parliament and all this stuff. But he's been seen.
是的。但我认为这是第一个主要的例子。所以托马斯·西摩然后，哦，天哪，我杀了国王的狗。这进展不顺利。所以他就跑了。然后第二天他假装什么都没发生。他四处闲逛，去议会等等。但他被看到了。
And so by the evening, he is in the Tower of London. For killing the King's dog or because people think there's some more. sinister design behind this? Yeah, of course they think it's a more sinister design. He's been trying to break into the King's private apartments. But for what purpose? It doesn't matter. He didn't want to beat him on the buttocks and stuff.
所以到了晚上，他就在伦敦塔里了。因为杀了国王的狗，还是因为人们认为这背后有什么更险恶的设计？是的，当然他们认为这是一个更险恶的设计。他一直试图闯入国王的私人公寓。但目的是什么？没关系。他不想打她的臀部之类的。
It doesn't matter. You weren't not allowed to break into the King's private apartments. I mean, obviously, he's trying to abduct him. I think that's the assumption. And that is treason. And that's why he gets sent to the tower. Right. Okay.
没关系。你不被允许闯入国王的私人公寓。我的意思是，显然，他试图绑架他。我认为这是假设。这就是叛国罪。这就是他被送进塔里的原因。好的。
And then three days later, Kate Ashley and Thomas Parry are also taken to the tower. So now Elizabeth is being drawn into the kind of the voice. vortex of the scandal. Yeah, the whole gang. Yeah. And unsurprisingly, when Elizabeth is informed that her two closest servants have been incarcerated, she was marvellously abashed and did weep very tenderly a long time. And her fears are for her servants, to whom she remains utterly loyal throughout this whole business, but also, of course, for herself, because she completely understands the mortal peril that she is now in. And what makes that peril even worse is that Kate and Thomas Parry both end up revealing to their interrogators the full details of Seymour's
然后三天后，凯特·阿什比和托马斯·帕里也被带到了塔里。所以现在伊丽莎白被卷入了丑闻的漩涡。是的，整个团伙。是的。不出所料，当伊丽莎白被告知她最亲近的两个仆人被监禁时，她非常惊慌，并非常温柔地哭了好长时间。她的恐惧是为她的仆人，她在这个整个事件中对他们保持绝对忠诚，但也当然，为她自己，因为她完全理解她现在所处的致命危险。而让这种危险更糟的是，凯特和托马斯·帕里最终都向审讯者透露了西摩的
inappropriate behaviour with her. So all the details that I've been, you know, quoting so far in this episode come from their testimony. And it's enough to get the interrogators to go and interview Elizabeth. And to repeat, she is just a teenage girl at this point, but she runs rings around her interrogators because she immediately acknowledges the truth of what Kate has revealed. I mean, she doesn't try to deny it. That would have been a very foolish move. She's even prepared to acknowledge that she liked Thomas Seymour, that she didn't absolutely detest his advances, but that she was only prepared to entertain them once
与她不当行为的全部细节。所以我在这一集中引用的所有细节都来自他们的证词。这足以让审讯者去采访伊丽莎白。再说一次，她此时只是一个十几岁的女孩，但她把审讯者耍得团团转，因为她立即承认了凯特所揭露的事实。我的意思是，她没有试图否认。那将是一个非常愚蠢的举动。她甚至准备承认她喜欢托马斯·西摩，她并不绝对厌恶他的追求，但她只准备在
the council had first granted its approval. And she's said enough that there is evidence that supports this claim. So as a result, it is apparent that she had never been complicit in Seymour's plot. And it's a brilliantly skillful performance from one so young. Her interrogators cannot pin anything on her. They can't show that she was plotting behind Edwards back to marry this man, that she was always operating within the set bounds of legality. And in due course, Kate and Thomas Perry are released, and though to begin with, Elizabeth is not allowed to take them back into her service by September 1549, they're back in her household.
议会首先给予批准后才考虑它们。她说得足够多了，有证据支持这一说法。因此，很明显，她从未参与西摩的阴谋。对于一个如此年轻的人来说，这是一个非常巧妙的表现。她的审讯者无法把任何事情归咎于她。他们无法证明她在爱德华背后密谋嫁给这个男人，她一直是在法律设定的范围内运作。最终，凯特和托马斯·帕里被释放，虽然起初，伊丽莎白不被允许让他们回到她的服务中，但到1549年9月，他们回到了她的家庭中。
And I think the experience for her was a very salutary one. And it confirmed her in an understanding of how politics operates in the nature of men and their desires and their ambitions and the advantages of studied ambiguity that will never leave her. There will be features of her life, her very long life, right the way up to the end. And Thomas Seymour, he ends up on the chopping block, doesn't he? He's executed on Tower Hill in the spring of 1549. He does. But that ambiguity, doesn't she write to Edward the 6th? And she says to him, it is as your majesty is not unaware,
我认为这对她来说是一次非常有益的经历。它证实了她对政治运作方式、男人及其欲望和野心的本质以及研究模糊性的优势的理解，这些将永远不会离开她。这将是她一生，她非常漫长的一生的特征，一直到最后。而托马斯·西摩，他最终上了断头台，不是吗？他在1549年春天在塔山被处决。他确实。但那种模糊性，她不是写信给爱德华六世吗？她对他说，正如陛下所知，
rather characteristic of my nature, not to say in words as much as I think in my mind. That's the key, I think. Yeah. But that again, I mean the Mary Queen of Scots parallel, Mary Queen of Scots is unguarded, isn't she? Yeah. And Elizabeth isn't. Yeah. They are always deep waters with Elizabeth and she's just a brilliant politician. And a brilliant strategist. So in the wake of Seymour's execution, she's got off, nothing's been pinned on her. But she's aware that she has to tread very carefully now. And so that's what she does. She dresses very modestly in black and white. You know, she's inherited from Anne Boleyn, a love of beautiful clothes. But for now, she plays the sober Protestant maid. And Edward is very impressed. You know, he's a very priggish Protestant by this point. And so he calls her sweet sister temperance. He thinks she's great.
我的天性有点特点，不是说出来的词语和我想在脑海里想的一样多。我认为这是关键。是的。但这再次，我的意思是苏格兰玛丽女王的平行，苏格兰玛丽女王是不设防的，不是吗？是的。而伊丽莎白不是。是的。伊丽莎白总是深不可测，她只是一个出色的政治家。和一个出色的战略家。所以在西摩被处决后，她逃脱了，没有任何事情被归咎于她。但她意识到她现在必须非常小心地行事。所以这就是她所做的。她穿得非常朴素，黑白相间。你知道，她从安妮·博林那里继承了对漂亮衣服的热爱。但现在，她扮演清醒的新教女仆。爱德华印象非常深刻。你知道，他此时是一个非常拘谨的新教徒。所以他称她为“甜蜜的节制姐姐”。他认为她很棒。
She continues her studies under Roger Asham, which she completes in 1550. So she's had, you know, the best education that anyone in Europe could have, basically. And she is increasingly cast by her admirers as a brilliantly educated woman. and by Protestants as a paragon of godly virtue. So is she a complete paragon? I mean, it has to be said that one feature of her character, we haven't yet brought out, and that is that she is monumentally acquisitive. And again, you can understand that, perhaps, psychologically,
她在罗杰·阿斯坎的指导下继续她的学业，她在1550年完成了学业。所以她基本上接受了欧洲任何人都能接受的最好的教育。她越来越被她的崇拜者塑造为一个受过良好教育的女性，被新教徒塑造为一个虔诚美德的典范。那么她是一个完美的典范吗？我的意思是，必须说她性格的一个特征，我们还没有提出来，那就是她非常贪婪。同样，你可以理解这一点，也许，从心理学上讲，
someone who's led such an unstable life. She'd want resources that are her own, and that she's not dependent upon anyone else to kind of access it. But, I mean, she does amazingly well. So by September 1550, which is when she takes, legal possession of Hatfield, so this house that she's grown up in, and it legally becomes her property, she's become the second largest landowner in the country. She declared at one stage that she couldn't even remember how many houses she had. So she's built up, I think, quite a power base for
一个过着如此不稳定生活的人。她会想要属于她自己的资源，并且她不依赖任何人来获取它。但是，我的意思是，她做得非常好。所以到1550年9月，也就是她取得哈特菲尔德的合法所有权时，也就是她长大的这栋房子，它合法地成为她的财产，她已经成为全国第二大土地所有者。她曾一度宣称她甚至不记得她有多少房子。所以她建立了一个相当大的权力基础，
herself. Yeah. The kind of the blots on her reputation have been clean. She's admired by the Protestant wing of opinion that is identified with her brother, the king. And she's got financial wherewithal, and, you know, land in England is always power. And this is just as well, because meanwhile, on the public stage, the Great Game of Thrones is continuing. So in January 1552, the Duke of Somerset, the Earthward Lord Protector, he's been toppled, and then he follows his brother to the block, and a new strong man emerges. And this is a guy called John Dudley, who is created the Earl of Northumberland. And this seems good news for Elizabeth. She gets on well with the Dudley family.
她自己。是的。她名声上的污点已经被洗清了。她受到与她哥哥国王认同的新教派别的钦佩。她有经济实力，而且，你知道，在英国土地总是权力。这很好，因为与此同时，在公共舞台上，伟大的权力的游戏正在继续。所以1552年1月，萨默塞特公爵，护国公，他被推翻了，然后他跟随他的兄弟上了断头台，一个新的强人出现了。这就是一个叫约翰·达德利的人，他被封为诺森伯兰伯爵。这对伊丽莎白来说似乎是个好消息。她和达德利家族相处得很好。
One of Northumberland's sons, Robert Dudley, is a particular playmate of hers, a friend of hers. He's a very handsome, dashing, charismatic man. And it is noted by contemporaries that he has a bit of a resemblance to Thomas Seymour. So there's something for listeners just to bear in mind. But all the while, so Elizabeth has basically kind of tied her fortunes to the Protestant wing, to her brother, to Northumberland, to Dudley. to people like that. But by the spring of 1553, it's becoming clear to those in the know that this
诺森伯兰的一个儿子，罗伯特·达德利，是她的特别玩伴，她的朋友。他是一个非常英俊、潇洒、有魅力的男人。同时代的人注意到他有点像托马斯·西摩。所以这有一些东西让听众记住。但一直以来，所以伊丽莎白基本上把她的命运与新教派别、她的哥哥、诺森伯兰、达德利联系在一起。与那样的人联系在一起。但到1553年春天，知情人士开始清楚，这
might not have been a good bet because Edward has fallen mortally ill. And Edward himself, we've been saying, he's a very vehement Protestant, he sees it as his duty to ensure a godly successor. So a successor who will carry on his work of reformation. And the problem for Edward is that listeners will remember, Henry's final act of succession, which had been passed in 1543, had prescribed that were Edward to die without having had children and Edward is still way too young to have had children at this point
可能不是一个好的赌注，因为爱德华病入膏肓。而爱德华本人，我们一直在说，他是一个非常激烈的新教徒，他认为确保一个虔诚的继任者是他的职责。所以一个将继续他的宗教改革工作的继任者。爱德华的问题是，听众会记得，亨利最后的继承法案，在1543年通过的，规定如果爱德华在没有孩子的情况下去世（而爱德华此时还太年轻，没有孩子），
then he will be succeeded by Mary and then if Mary dies by Elizabeth but Edward is unwilling to countenance this Mary is a Catholic and Elizabeth even though she's you know Protestant maiden all that she is as Edward tells his counsellors
那么他将由玛丽继位，如果玛丽去世，则由伊丽莎白继位。但爱德华不愿意容忍这一点。玛丽是天主教徒，而伊丽莎白，尽管她是，你知道，新教女仆，所有这些，正如爱德华告诉他的顾问们，
a bastard and sprang from an illegitimate bed and so it is that in June 1553 he comes up with what he terms my device for the succession. And by its terms, both Mary and Elizabeth are disinherited, and the crown is settled instead on their cousin, Lady Jane Gray, who is, of course, both Protestant and impeccably legitimate. And of course, she has the backing, ultimately, of the Duke of Northumberland, the new kind of
是一个私生子，出自非法的床。所以，在1553年6月，他提出了他所谓的“我的继承计划”。根据其条款，玛丽和伊丽莎白都被剥夺了继承权，王位反而定给了她们的表亲，简·格雷女勋爵，她当然既是新教徒，又是无可挑剔的合法继承人。当然，她最终得到了诺森伯兰公爵的支持，他是新政权的某种
a strong man of the regime, because his son, Guildford, splendidly named son, has married her. There's more about Guilford and his comedy voice. Exactly. In our episodes on Lady Jane Gray. Yeah. And so basically he says, yeah, fine, okay, I'm in. I'm in on this. And he gets the council to back it.
强人，因为他的儿子，吉尔福德，名字很棒的儿子，娶了她。关于吉尔福德和他的喜剧声音还有更多内容。没错。在我们关于简·格雷的剧集中。是的。所以基本上他说，是的，好的，我加入。我加入这个。他让议会支持它。
And so when Edward dies on the 6th of July, four days later, Northumberland, his allies on the council, proclaim Jane Queen. But it all goes horribly wrong. Mary refuses to accept her deposition. Dominic on record as being a big admirer of her pluck. Yeah. She shows tremendous pluck. and the vast mass of the English people back her.
所以当爱德华在7月6日去世时，四天后，诺森伯兰和他在议会中的盟友宣布简为女王。但一切都变得非常糟糕。玛丽拒绝接受她的废黜。多米尼克记录在案，是她勇气的崇拜者。是的。她表现出了巨大的勇气。而绝大多数英国人民支持她。
By the 3rd of August, the entire attempt to install Lady Jane Grey as Queen has collapsed. Mary makes this triumphant entry into London. There are bells, there are bonfires, there are cheering crowds, tossing their caps into the air, all of that. And by this point, Jane and Guilford have been sent to the tower. And so too has Guilford's brother and Elizabeth's particular chum, Robert Dudley. So he's gone there. And on the 22nd of August, Robert Dudley's dad, the Earl of Northumberland, is beheaded for treason on Tower Hill. And he has recanted his Protestantism by this point, because of course
到8月3日，整个让简·格雷女勋爵成为女王的尝试已经崩溃。玛丽凯旋进入伦敦。有钟声，有篝火，有欢呼的人群，把帽子扔向空中，所有这些。到这个时候，简和吉尔福德已经被送进了塔里。吉尔福德的兄弟和伊丽莎白的特别好友罗伯特·达德利也被送进去了。所以他去了那里。8月22日，罗伯特·达德利的父亲，诺森伯兰伯爵，因叛国罪在塔山被斩首。到这个时候他已经放弃了他的新教信仰，因为当然
there is now, in the form of Mary, a Catholic queen. But it doesn't help him. He still has his head chopped off. But it's a reminder that the age of the Protestant king, Edward VI, is over. And there is now a Catholic queen on the throne in the form of Mary. And Elizabeth has sat this out. Hasn't she by and large? She has been keeping a very low profile, at Hatfield House, basically waiting to see what happens. So again, a sign of her, you know, she's very canny. She doesn't want to kind of, you know, stake all her chips
现在，以玛丽的形式，有一位天主教女王。但这对他没有帮助。他仍然被砍了头。但这提醒人们，新教国王爱德华六世的时代结束了。现在王位上有一位天主教女王，以玛丽的形式。而伊丽莎白坐视不管。她基本上没有吗？她一直保持着非常低调的姿态，在哈特菲尔德庄园，基本上等着看会发生什么。所以再次，一个她的标志，你知道，她非常精明。她不想，你知道，把她所有的筹码都押上。
until she knows exactly how things are going to play out. I think also there's a sense that Mary's triumph is her triumph as well. Because had Jane succeeded to the throne, then she would have been disinherited as well as Mary. Yeah. And now, for the first time since the execution of Ambell, in, she is the heir to the throne. As long as Mary doesn't have children.
直到她确切地知道事情将如何发展。我认为人们也有一种感觉，玛丽的胜利也是她的胜利。因为如果简继承了王位，那么她和玛丽一样都会被剥夺继承权。是的。现在，自安妮·博林被处决以来，她第一次成为了王位继承人。只要玛丽没有孩子。
Yeah, of course. But that, of course, is also a cause of danger for her. Because Mary, as a Catholic queen, is not going to want to be succeeded by a Protestant. Yeah, of course. And so how this plays out, we will find in our next episode. And it's a drama of sibling rivalries that will feature for Elizabeth. Perils greater than any, she's faced up to this. this point. And, you know, don't want to give away too much, but we will be revisiting
是的，当然。但这当然也是她面临危险的原因。因为玛丽作为一位天主教女王，不会希望由一位新教徒来继承她的王位。是的，当然。至于事情将如何发展，我们将在下一集中揭晓。这是一场姐妹间的竞争，对伊丽莎白来说，这将带来比她迄今为止所面临的任何危险都要大的危机。而且，你知道，我不想剧透太多，但我们将重返
the Tower of London. So next time we'll be in the Tower of London with Elizabeth I, during the reign of her sister Mary. Now, if you want to listen to that and the rest of this series right away, if you remember the Rest is History Club, of course you can. You could be listening to it right now instead of listening to me, wittering on. However, if you'd like to join, you merely need to head to the rest is history.com. And you'll get all kinds of wonderful treats and benefits as well. And on that bumshel, Tom, thank you very much. That was brilliant. Bye-bye, everybody. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
伦敦塔。所以下一次，我们将和伊丽莎白一世一起，在她姐姐玛丽统治时期身处伦敦塔。现在，如果你想立即收听那一集以及本系列的其余部分，如果你是“历史余韵”俱乐部的成员，当然可以。你现在就可以听，而不是听我在这里喋喋不休。不过，如果你想加入，只需前往therestishistory.com。你还会得到各种美妙的款待和福利。说到这里，汤姆，非常感谢你。这太精彩了。再见，大家。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。